[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos desde hace bastante
tiempo aquí en visual políticos venimos
contando como áfrica ha comenzado a
girar a cambiar su posición en la ruleta
de la fortuna económica os hemos hablado
ampliamente por ejemplo de los casos de
ruanda o etiopía dos países que hasta
hace pocos años encontraban entre los
más pobres del continente africano pero
que ahora contra viento y marea han
comenzado a despegar
[Música]
sin embargo a pesar de ello estoy seguro
de que si yo repito la pregunta la
respuesta va a seguir siendo
prácticamente la misma que es lo primero
que se te viene a la cabeza cuando
piensas en el áfrica sub-sahariana pues
estoy seguro o segurísimo de que para la
mayoría de vosotros la respuesta
seguiría siendo la de siempre pobreza
dificultades y tragedias ahora bien como
ya os hemos contado en varias ocasiones
en muchos casos ese escenario
prototípico está comenzando a cambiar
claro que como siempre siempre repetimos
la evidencia nos dice que el futuro ni
está escrito ni áfrica es un único país
es decir que vamos a poder encontrar
realidades y tendencias muy pero que muy
diferentes
por ejemplo no es lo mismo hablar de
kenia que de tanzania a pesar de ser dos
países fronterizos que lograron su
independencia casi simultáneamente y
cuyas economías en ese momento tenían un
nivel de renta similar hoy en cambio en
paridad de poder adquisitivo esto es
teniendo en cuenta la diferencia de
precios los géneros son un 80% más ricos
que sus vecinos tras la independencia a
los dos países se convirtieron en sendas
dictaduras pero mientras que kenia logró
transitar hacia un modelo más
democrático orientado al mercado tan tan
ya quedó sometida durante décadas bajo
una dictadura de corte socialista que
nacionalizó las grandes empresas y forzó
a la gente a trabajar en granjas
colectivas
tampoco es lo mismo hablar de zimbabwe
que de botsuana a pesar de que también
son dos países fronterizos y a pesar de
que en 1980 el primero pues era bastante
más rico que el segundo una situación
muy pero que muy diferente a la actual
porque amigos hoy botsuana un país que
apostó por la estabilidad y la economía
de mercado no sólo es siete veces más
rica que zimbabwe sino que en términos
per cápita miremos cómo lo miremos y en
un nivel de renta superior al de países
como colombia brasil o ecuador
así que ya lo veis lo cierto es que si
no nos ponemos el traje de exploradores
vamos a poder encontrar realidades muy
diferentes dentro del áfrica sub
sahariana unas diferencias que cada vez
serán más acusadas es el fenómeno de lo
que ya se conoce como los leones
africanos países que tras décadas de
corte o masiva violencia el
enriquecimiento sistemático de élites
oligárquicas o la influencia del
socialismo africano con una ideología
política alimentada apoyada y
promocionada por la unión soviética y
cuba durante la segunda mitad del siglo
20 ahora ahora han comenzado a despegar
porque de la pobreza se sale pero ojo
porque no es un camino tan sencillo
queridos amigos de visual político en
esta ocasión vamos a echar un vistazo a
una historia muy diferente de la que
todos imaginamos cuando pensamos en el
áfrica sub-sahariana estáis preparados
para embarcarnos con nosotros en este
nuevo viaje a lo desconocido pues
arranquemos bienvenidos a mauricio
[Música]
más prosperidad de áfrica
mauricio una república insular formada
por cuatro islas principales y situada
en pleno océano índico a unos mil
kilómetros de distancia de madagascar un
lugar en el que para desplazarse a
europa o américa normalmente se
necesitarán [ __ ] varios aviones
hablamos de un país muy pequeñito de
apenas unos dos mil kilómetros cuadrados
una ex colonia francesa primero y más
tarde británica que a pesar de todo ha
sido el único país africano en colarse
en el primer escalafón del índice de
desarrollo humano que anualmente elabora
naciones unidas- un país amigos que los
60 era completamente dependiente de los
cultivos de caña de azúcar pero que
ahora ahora tiene uno de los hawks
financieros y turísticos más importantes
de toda áfrica es hoy un pedido de pre
cápita ajustado por el nivel de precios
el banco mundial calcula en unos 24.000
dólares ojo casi tanto como chile y 6
veces superior a la media del áfrica
subsahariana ahora bien llegados a este
punto posiblemente muchos os estaréis
preguntando vale vale enrique pero como
como demonios consigue un pequeño remoto
país insular situado o lejos de
cualquier otro lugar del mundo escapar
de la pobreza extrema y pasar de
cultivar caña de azúcar para sobrevivir
a convertirse en un nodo financiero
turístico pues bien la clave amigos está
en una serie de reformas políticas
económicas legales y sociales que
convirtieron al país
en uno de los más seguros jurídicamente
de toda áfrica sino el que más
en los años 70 a mauricio sufrió una
dura crisis económica que se fue
gestando años atrás por la falta de
diversificación de su pobre economía
agraria un alto nivel de desempleo una
población que crecía demasiado rápido y
una pequeña élite política y social que
concentraba la mayor parte de la riqueza
y no precisamente por procesos de
mercado por supuesto con semejante
panorama y teniendo además en cuenta su
ubicación el país estaba aislado de los
mercados internacionales y su capacidad
para lograr financiación e inversión
extranjera era prácticamente nula
mauricio necesitaba para escapar de ese
pozo poner en marcha profundas reformas
políticas y económicas y amigos
sorprendentemente teniendo en cuenta la
realidad africana de la época eso es
exactamente lo que hicieron pusieron en
marcha un enorme paquete de reformas que
podemos dividir en tres fases
la primera en la década de los 70 y
aprovechando las rentas del azúcar
supuso la creación de una zona de
procesamiento de exportaciones algo así
como una zona económica especial un área
acotada en la que el gobierno implantó
una serie de beneficios fiscales y
regulatorios con el objetivo de impulsar
la producción industrial y las
exportaciones y sabéis que como en
tantos otros sitios aquí el experimento
está primera aproximación al libre
mercado mundial también fue un éxito en
poco tiempo se instalaron manufacturas
de nueve sectores diferentes el 90% de
las empresas eran locales y a tenor de
los resultados las autoridades de
mauricio se dieron cuenta de que oye eso
de crear una economía orientada al resto
del mundo pues podría ser algo muy pero
que muy lucrativo que podrían compensar
vaya a su remota situación geográfica
así que dicho y hecho
en la segunda fase de reformas entre la
década de 1980 y 1990 que se expandía
esta zona de procesamiento de
exportaciones y se ampliaron sus
ventajas el resultado es que se disparó
la inversión extranjera y un nuevo
sector comenzó a florecer desde cero el
turismo un sector que ha sido
fundamental para el desarrollo de
mauricio y que hoy supone cerca del 20
por ciento del pib en el país no por
casualidad pues la isla principal es
conocida como la isla playa pero amigos
las reformas no acabaron ahí en esta
segunda fase también se liberalizaron
los movimientos de capital se implantó
un modelo de impuestos bajos se
eliminaron muchas de las regulaciones
existentes e incluso durante un tiempo
se estableció el secreto bancario lo que
pasaba a mauricio se quedaba en mauricio
algo que por cierto le costó al país
estar durante años hasta el 2019 en las
listas nacionales e internacionales de
paraísos fiscales o jurisdicciones no
colaboradoras
[Música]
el caso es que de esta forma mauricio
desarrolló una cultura económica muy
orientada a las finanzas y el libre
mercado por ejemplo el impuesto sobre
los beneficios bien a situarse en un 15%
porcentaje que se reduce a entre el 0 y
el 3 por ciento para las empresas extra
territoriales es decir empresas que
localizan en mauricio su sede fiscal
pero cuyas actividades se concentran
fuera del país en mauricio por cierto
tampoco existe el impuesto sobre las
ganancias de capital esto es por ejemplo
sobre los dividendos o los intereses
recibidos
semejante arquitectura económica que fue
además mejorada y consolidada durante la
tercera fase entre los años 1990 y 2010
hizo que la inversión en el país se
multiplicará al tiempo que se desarrolló
toda una industria financiera
internacional bancos gestoras de fondos
de inversión empresas de seguros e
incluso un lucrativo negocio de
sociedades radicadas para mejorar su
estructura fiscal y amigos para que os
hagáis una idea de lo que estamos
hablando según las estimaciones de la
comisión de servicios financieros del
país y mauricio están registradas más de
21 mil corporaciones internacionales
cuyos activos repartidos por todo el
mundo superan la cifra de los
seiscientos mil millones de dólares más
de 40 veces el pib el nacional es lo que
mauricio se conoce mayormente como las
compañías de negocios globales que bc
por sus siglas en inglés son sociedades
residentes de mauricio y por lo tanto
obligadas fiscalmente en este país pero
cuyas acciones sin embargo están
mayoritariamente controladas por
personas o empresas no residentes en
mauricio y que además se dedican a
realizar negocios principalmente en el
extranjero
pero aquí no termina todo incluso
durante las últimas dos décadas el
número de millonarios residentes en este
lugar ha crecido más rápido que en
cualquier otro lugar africano lo que
lógicamente también ha sido auténtica
una gasolina para su industria de
gestión de fondos financieros según
datos de la frase am bank el número de
extranjeros residentes y mauricio con un
patrimonio neto superior al millón de
dólares se ha triplicado durante la
última década son ya casi cuatro mil
millonarios procedentes sobre todo de
francia y su gráfica y es que oye playas
seguridad y bajos impuestos pues a quien
no le gusta ahora bien un momento nos
hemos el freno que os conozco enrique un
paraíso fiscal de verdad nos estás
hablando de un paraíso fiscal está claro
que no deja de ser algo controvertido
incluso en que hablemos del único país
del áfrica subsahariana que ha logrado
un nivel de desarrollo humano muy alto y
por esto amigos hay algunas preguntas
que llegaron a este punto nos podemos
hacer que mauricio se convirtiera en una
especie de paraíso fiscal fue algo bueno
o malo para el resto del continente
africano como logro ganarse la confianza
de tantos inversores internacionales que
tenía por ejemplo mauricio que no
tuvieran países como libería belice o
vanuatu que también han sido
considerados países no colaboradores en
materia fiscal pues bien empecemos por
la primera cuestión
[Música]
amigos puede que muchos habéis tenido la
tentación de pensar que la existencia de
lugares como mauricio han sido algo malo
para el resto del áfrica subsahariana
sin embargo nada más lejos de la
realidad y antes de que os lances a
mikko yo dejadme explicarme veréis el 60
por ciento de las inversiones de
empresas internacionales registradas en
mauricio que se canalizan desde este
lugar vaya tienen como destino los
países de áfrica continental minas
hoteles fábricas promociones
inmobiliarias etcétera etcétera hablamos
por tanto de inversiones que obviamente
generan empleos producción y actividad
económica de todo tipo en esos países no
sólo mauricio actividades empezar las
cuales por cierto los estados africanos
donde se localizan también reciben
impuestos como por ejemplo impuestos
sobre el trabajo el consumo o los
propios inmuebles es decir que capturan
impuestos de la riqueza generada por
esas inversiones pero entonces la
pregunta es por qué registrar o
canalizar estas inversiones desde
mauricio pues amigos no sólo se trata de
una cuestión fiscal de impuestos hay
otro elemento incluso más importante que
es precisamente lo que también
diferencia a este país de otros paraísos
fiscales como liberia o belice atentos
mauricio cuenta con uno de los sistemas
jurídicos y políticos más garantistas de
toda áfrica un sistema que otorga mucha
seguridad jurídica a sus ciudadanos y
también a los inversores extranjeros de
esta forma este país cuenta con un
sistema judicial considerado por los
organismos internacionales como bastante
eficaz e independiente elecciones libres
y mayoritariamente limpias un nivel
relativamente alto de libertad de
expresión y una estructura de poderes
equilibrada donde el presidente el
primer ministro y la asamblea nacional
se reparten las funciones y el poder
actuando así como contrapesos
y no sólo eso según el banco mundial
mauricio se ha convertido en uno de los
13 países de todo el mundo donde más
fácil resulta hacer negocios y según el
índice de libertad económica de la
heritage foundation es una de las 25
economías más libres del planeta y la
número uno de áfrica pues bien son
precisamente todas estas características
lo que lo convierten en un país
relativamente seguro y estable y ese es
el motivo por el que los extranjeros
optan por registrar depositar y
canalizar en está aquí sus inversiones
en el áfrica sub-sahariana
os lo hemos contado muchas veces por muy
bajos que tengan los impuestos y
inseguridad jurídica y estabilidad
política pues no te servirán de nada
claro nadie va a llevar su dinero por
muy bajos que sean los impuestos a un
lugar donde le pueden robar
flagrantemente ahora bien llegados a
este punto puede que muchos os estáis
preguntando si el progreso económico de
mauricio realmente además de favorecer a
muchas empresas también ha favorecido a
los propios mauricianos a ver ya sabemos
cómo son estas cosas no es extraño sobre
todo teniendo en cuenta que hablamos de
áfrica sub-sahariana que al final las
buenas noticias se queden en buenas
noticias tan sólo para unos pocos pues
bien la respuesta rápida es que este no
es el caso de mauricio
[Música]
la pobreza en el país se ha reducido
hasta el 12 7% en 2019 y hoy la pobreza
extrema está prácticamente erradicada
del país menos del 1% se encuentra en
ese escalafón todo eso se ha conseguido
gracias a un crecimiento económico anual
medio del 4,6 por ciento entre los años
1977 y 2008 un crecimiento que además le
ha permitido al país reducir su
coeficiente de gini de igualdad hasta
unos niveles cercanos a los de países
como españa australia o reino unido lo
que nos dice que todo ese crecimiento
económico ha favorecido a todas las
capas de la población
y amigos con los datos en la mano parece
claro que estamos ante un nuevo león
africano un león del que quizás pocas
veces habéis escuchado hablar ahora bien
quiere decir todo esto que un lugar como
mauricio está encaminado a conquistar su
plaza entre el ranking de los países más
ricos y desarrollados del mundo pues
amigos no resulta tan sencillo atentos
ue de mauricio acabar como el 2do ojo
además de por sus playas y durante años
su secreto bancario
mauricio también es conocido por ser la
isla del todo una pequeña ave no
voladora endémica de este lugar pero que
se extinguió ya en el siglo 17 pues bien
ahora son muchos los analistas que se
preguntan si esta especie de milagro o
despegue económico de mauricio no corre
el riesgo de terminar igual de mal tal y
como os podéis imaginar en un país tan
dependiente del turismo en las
inversiones internacionales pues la
crisis del coro' nabil está azotando muy
pero que muy fuerte a esta pequeña
república para que os hagáis una idea el
pib se enfrenta a una caída histórica al
tiempo que el déficit público se ha
disparado por encima del 20 por ciento y
el registro de nuevas empresas offshore
pues se ha desplomado sin embargo
esperar un momento porque aunque lo más
probable es que en este caso los efectos
de coronavirus sean pasajeros lo que más
preocupa de este país insular es la
transformación que está llevando a cabo
en su modelo económico fijaos
desde 2018 mauricio está realizando
importantes cambios en su sistema fiscal
y bancario cambios que eliminan ciertas
ventajas con el objetivo de dejar de ser
considerado por los organismos
internacionales como una jurisdicción
fiscal que no coopera asimismo el país
también está construyendo un modelo
impositivo más similar al de los países
desarrollados con un incremento general
de todos los tipos impositivos aunque
eso sí seguirán siendo mucho más bajos
que la mayoría de los países
desarrollados al tiempo que también han
seguido poniendo en marcha cambios para
favorecer la atracción de capitales por
ejemplo desde 2018 han reducido el
capital mínimo de 100 mil dólares
necesarios para abrir una empresa justo
a la mitad
es decir maurice se enfrenta al reto de
dejar de ser estrictamente lo que
conocemos como un paraíso fiscal regido
por el total anonimato para
transformarse así en un modelo de país
con bajos impuestos y pocas regulaciones
pero plenamente homologable a la
realidad internacional un modelo en el
que el estado tendrá mayor peso que el
que ha tenido durante las últimas
décadas somos una pequeña isla que está
limitada en muchos sentidos no tenemos
ningún recurso natural necesitamos tener
una ventaja sobre los demás para ser
atractivos así que creo que la ventaja
en la tributación es importante para
bing iucn out primer ministro de
mauricio digamos que la idea de la élite
local es que mauricio evolucione de ser
esencialmente un centro financiero y
turístico para convertirse también en un
importante enclave comercial de cara a
las transacciones con el áfrica
sub-sahariana algo así como en singapur
de áfrica la puerta de entrada y salida
al continente más desconocido para los
capitales las inversiones y también el
comercio un puente entre áfrica y asia
la pregunta es serán sus bajos impuestos
y su seguridad jurídica suficiente para
mantener su buena marcha económica
seguirá siendo mauricio un ejemplo de
estabilidad y desarrollo para el resto
del continente o por contra su final
como paraísos fiscales será el ocaso de
su intachable trayectoria económica
queridos amigos esta que hemos visto es
la historia de uno de los leones
africanos más desconocidos pero al mismo
tiempo también uno de los más exitosos
un país que no solo demuestra que
escapar de la pobreza es posible incluso
en áfrica sino que se ha convertido en
buena medida en todo un modelo a seguir
para el resto de países del continente
un modelo que en cierta forma algunos
otros países como costa de marfil están
empezando a imitar para tratar de
convertirse en los siguientes otros
africanos pero de todo ellos hablaremos
en un próximo vídeo aquí en visual
político así que ya sabéis no olvidéis
suscribiros al canal si es que aún no lo
habéis hecho para estar al tanto de
todas nuestras novedades y por supuesto
si estáis resultó interesante no
olvidéis darle al botón de like un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]